de Vaca Muerta Shale formation in
Argentina's Patagonia is home to some of
the largest and conventional oil and gas
deposits in the world even though it was
first discovered a century ago
exploration and development in the area
began recently and it has changed the
life of an Yello a small town located in
the province of loken forever
Graciela Kenya came to fine work
she says thousands of others are doing
the same deficit for the camp removal
area there is a real state deficit not
only companies are bringing people to
work here but there are others who come
to find work because there is full
employment here my grandson found a job
in a few days
that doesn't happen anywhere else in the
country the oil and gas industry is
booming here and companies from around
the world are flocking to vaca muerta
which means dead cow in Spanish it
occupies four provinces in the country
covering an area of 30,000 square
kilometers vaca muerta remains largely
untapped and that's why Argentina needs
foreign companies to help explore and
exploit this area but the current
economic crisis and government policies
pose a major challenge to this area that
if well developed could help solve
Argentina's endemic economic problems
last month the government announced that
contracts would be paid at asset
exchange rate far weaker than the market
rate it also froze an increase in the
price of fuel for 90 days now
it authorized a small increase but
companies investing here are worried and
some have frozen their operations the
thermo parada is the leader of the
powerful oil workers labor union he says
vaca muerta needs predictability in this
activity that cannot be uncertainty you
need to give clear steps this business
needs to be run like everywhere else in
the world why do we have to be different
we all have this wealth and should be
able to generate job stability we want
to create legislation that regardless of
who is in power in Argentina it cannot
be changed in details who the business
needs to be run but development in this
area comes with a cost
to get the oil and gas out companies use
cracking last year Greenpeace Turkish
total and British Dutch group shell of
dumping highly toxic waste threatening
wildlife and human health in the area
the extraction of oil and gas is not
ecological we have to begin with that it
has an impact on the environment and the
residues of what they extract end up
somewhere we have to develop more plants
to deal with these residues and need
more investment in these areas we have
to mitigate the impact of future
generations
Argentina is in desperate need of funds
and vaca muerta is one of the ways it
has to get them but only a serious
long-term government plan is what will
guarantee that what is extracted here
will change
Argentina's future for good para Sawa al
Jazeera vaca muerta Argentina